refugees are people who are are just
trying to set up life they have lost
everything except for one another and
they find themselves here looking for
help to start over again I miss fed my
family so much fun as I keep it playing
every day for them God protect them and
let them safe please have now confirmed
at least four attacks in the city of
Paris we're here because of a shooting
that we had am a student we had at the
inland regional center just up the
street here to deadly attacks one in
Paris France another in San Bernardino
California have rattled the American
people they're skeptical and afraid of
allowing refugees from the Middle East
into this country GOP presidential
frontrunner Donald Trump has fed that
fear with vivid descriptions of a secret
invasion could very well be the ultimate
Trojan horse this would be greater than
the example of the Trojan horses would
blow the Trojan horse away many
Americans are afraid 51 percent of
voters oppose allowing Syrian refugees
into the United States according to a
recent national poll Paris and more
recently San Bernardino have caused
people to have a raised awareness about
how safe their own neighborhood is mike
loong is the executive director of voice
of the refugees a faith-based nonprofit
in anaheim california that helps
refugees settle in America he's also a
Baptist pastor although we're a
Christian organization we are seeking to
show Christ's love to anyone who needs
assistance who fits in the refugee or
asylee category we do work with a large
number of Muslims who come in but also
fleeing Christians from other countries
Oakland Athenian how to be a book that
they definitely feet long and his team
help refugees with food shelter
childcare education employment the
basics of life the wave of Syrian
refugees hasn't yet hit American shores
but long has dealt with thousands of
refugees and trusts the vetting system
we walk in them with open arms
fortunately for us the security and all
of the checks that would need to go
through health everything else like that
is done by other agencies so what
exactly is the refugee vetting process
as it turns out most of that information
is public
a refugee begins his or her journey to
America in a different country this is
opposed to an asylum who must physically
come to the United States in order to
seek asylum the first agency most
refugees will encounter is the United
Nations High refugee Commissioner which
provides health education and other
services to refugees around the world
and is heavily involved in helping
refugees transition out of temporary
camps into more permanent homes the
State Department describes the UNHRC as
the initial filter the small number of
cases that pass through this filter then
conduct an interview at a resettlement
Support Center contracted by the
government they then face scrutiny by
the Department of Homeland Security
which reviews the compiled information
and conducts its own interviews with the
potential refugees and then tries to
corroborate the details with the help of
various other intelligence and military
agencies including the FBI in the
Defense Department both of which run
their own separate background checks a
little more than fifty percent of the
refugees that have made it this far past
this multiple agency screening process
Syrian refugees go through an additional
layer of screening called the Syria
enhanced review next there's a health
screening to check for any communicable
diseases and then the cultural
orientation class is to give refugees an
idea of what to expect in America
finally there's one more round of
security checks to verify that no new
information was on earth before the
refugee may finally board a plane to the
United States upon arrival of Customs
and Border Patrol agent rechecked the
paperwork to verify the refugee is the
person she claims to be before releasing
her to a volunteer agency Lake voice of
refugees the entire process takes an
average of 18 to 24 months half the
Syrian refugees taken into the US so far
have been children another quarter are
older than 60 only two percent are
single males of comp at age if any one
of those people who are professing to
know what we should do have actually
been in contact with a refugee I believe
their stance would change because it's
people engaging people who have great
need
in our country Syria they start war
there after four months we came here
this woman who asked that our name be
withheld for the safety of her family in
Syria came to the United States with her
husband and two daughters five years ago
as the Syrian civil war began the
government granted the family asylum my
family they said never ever think come
back because the war start now so
dangers Isis they destroy everything
just they took all the village now and
we have hard time now they live in even
my family they live in dangerous now
they have lost everything except for one
another and they find themselves here
looking for help to start over again I
just like start take my my English here
from ESL class two years after that I
start all part-time the voice of images
provide walk to my husband he find work
he changed many walks but praise the
Lord he he can walk at this time because
we have work permit with us they have
been professionals who have left their
profession their home and everything and
they come and have to start over here
the adjustment is something that I don't
know that I even fully myself comprehend
before we came here like it's a good
life there before the war start even i'm
a teacher music i'm studing music 10
years and i start work with with the
children USA it's a dream for us you
know it's not like my country we don't
have freedom if you are Christian days
they persecute you it's not easy you
cannot practice like here we don't have
freedom most of the people they drink
come here because freedom of religion
freedom of speech Americans may be more
open to allowing in Christians like this
woman and her family but what about
Muslims if we're worried that Isis is
going to have more of an inroad than it
had before the ideology is something we
can't protect ourselves from its people
who are deciding that life has no value
and that a way of looking at other
people that they would have looked at
earlier in their lives it's completely
changed they throw it out the window
we can't police against that Isis
represents an idea and borders can't
stop ideas a man born in the United
States and his Saudi Arabian wife
carried out the San Bernardino attack
it's really sad to see that the world
has taken the victim and now labeled
them or has the sphere of them being the
perpetrator suhail mola is the associate
director at Access California another
nonprofit that provides social services
to refugees he's also an imam a Muslim
pastor really you're talking about a
population that's broken they're the
ones who are the victims of all of that
conflict there they're sick of the the
government and it stanzas they're sick
of the militants and their stances
they're sick of the rebels Isis anybody
and everybody who has to do with them
not being able to be home I don't know
the internal workings of Isis and what
they're planning but I do know that with
proper screening those matters can be
easily determined and what they'll find
is that those that are trying to leave
Syria they're trying to leave Syria
because they they can't call it home
anymore because their homes are
destroyed no one who has a desire to
wear a vest and become a human bomb is
going to put it on the back burner for
four years and go through a process of
becoming a regular refugee that's not
their mo the 911 attackers were all in
the US on tourists or student visas the
LAX shooter was here on a tourist visa
and denied Asylum the fort hood shooter
was an American born citizen the only
relevant case of an attack carried out
on us soil is the Boston Marathon
bombing which involved two brothers who
were not refugees but the children of
asylees so far the US has led in about
2,000 Syrian refugees in the past four
years Obama's proposed plan allows about
10,000 more this would account for about
point zero zero four of the
sting US population it's my dream I will
continue here now I'm study early
childhood development and i hope i will
graduate very soon i dream good future
for my children I don't want them see
what we saw before in my childhood is
not easy I want them live good life even
for my family I hope one day they will
come here it's a dream for me it's for
me and what impossible but for god it's
possible he can bring them one day
you